كشفت مجموعة من أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
هذا الأسبوع عن تشريع من شأنه أن
يحدد سن 13 عامًا باعتباره الحد الأدنى الوطني
لسن استخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وإنشاء
معايير صارمة للتحقق من عمر المستخدم مما
يجعل الشباب يشعرون بنفس الطرق
التي لا نريدها نحن كآباء وكمجتمع.  إن
ما يشعرون به
هو جزء لا يتجزأ من نموذج الأعمال، حيث
يتطلب مشروع القانون المقترح أيضًا
موافقة الوالدين للمستخدمين الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 13 و17 عامًا، ويمنع
منصات التكنولوجيا من استخدام
المعلومات الشخصية للمراهقين لاستهدافهم
بالمحتوى أو الإعلانات.
يقع على عاتق شركات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي واجب المساعدة في الحفاظ على
سلامة الأطفال و  أبلغ الآباء أو يواجهون
عواقب وخيمة، يقول المشرعون إن
التشريع يتماشى مع توجيهات
الجراح العام الأمريكي، فالبيئة المنحرفة
والمشوهة في كثير من الأحيان
لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي غالبًا ما تضر بالعديد
من هؤلاء الأطفال.
المشكلة ويقول إن لديه
مخاوف بشأن هذا الإصدار.
يتفق المدافعون عن مساءلة التكنولوجيا على أن مشروع القانون
يركز على القضية الخاطئة.
لا يضع مشروع القانون هذا في الواقع أي مسؤولية
على عاتق شركات التكنولوجيا، بل
يضع المزيد من المسؤولية على عاتق الآباء
والشباب لممارسة نوع من الشرطة الذاتية  تجادل
نيكول جيل من
منظمة Accountable tech غير الربحية بأنها أطلقت
شركات تقنية محفزة لإعادة تصميم
منصاتها لحماية الصحة العقلية
والخصوصية، ولدينا فرصة
الآن لإعادة التفكير في الطريقة التي
تعمل بها هذه المنصات للشباب
ويجب أن نتخذها